l'hôpital public en danger c'est le cri
d'alarmé des personnels de santé comme
des citoyens de plus en plus nombreux à
se mobiliser
un collectif de parents se bat ainsi
pour la défense des urgences
pédiatriques en ile-de-france est cet
hiver à cause des fermetures de lits 25
enfants ont dû être transférés jusqu'à
200 kilomètres des urgences les plus
proches de leur domicile
le récit de katia technique il faut
sauver la réanimation pédiatrique
les services d'urgence qui accueille les
enfants en danger de mort un cri
d'alarmé a été lancée par des citoyens
des parents qui se mobilisent contre la
fermeture des lits dans les urgences
pédiatriques d'île de france cet hiver
faute de place 25 enfants ont dû être
transférés hors d'île de france à rouen
amiens lille orléans une situation
inacceptable que dénonce l'appel des
parents de l'area pédiatrique qui a
lancé une pétition destinée au président
de la république et agnès buzyn la
ministre de la santé était à 5000
signatures il a un peu moins de 10 jours
et qu'aujourd'hui on oublie les 159 85
ans ce jeune couple a eu recours aux
services des urgences pédiatriques
durant de longs mois pour deux de ses
bébés lors de sa grossesse sophie a été
hospitalisé et risque est de perdre sa
fille
mais faute de lits le service l'a pressé
de rentrer chez elle
j'ai déclenché un hématome heures est
trop placentaire à à 29 semaines de
grossesse et à ce moment là si j'avais
écouté justement le personnel soignant
qui me préconisait de rentrer chez moi
comme on a une demi heure pour
intervenir sinon le bébé n'est plus
oxygéné clairement romy n'aurait pas
survécu
la décision des médecins n'étaient pas
un débat n'est pas d'une décision de
médecine vraiment mais été subies par
des choix administratif de l'hôpital
ses parents qui ont connu l'angoissé du
transfert pour leur nouveau-né dénonce
les transports d'enfants dont la vie ne
tient qu'à un fil un enfant qui est
entre la vie et la mort peut rester
coincée dans des embouteillages
il peut très bien avoir un accident il
ya plein de paramètres qui peuvent faire
que la vie de l'enfant est vraiment en
danger et
on accroît ses risques en faisant ce
genre de transfert donc c'est
inadmissible aujourd'hui le collectif se
bat pour venir en aide aux personnels
qui sont entrés en grève démarre 2019
pour réclamer davantage dans bausch
notre deuxième enfant elle a clairement
été sauvés par leur réactivité par par
le service des urgences pédiatriques et
de la réanimation
s'il avait fallu à déplacer s'il y avait
eu la moindre défaillance en taille
réelle juste pas survécu donc on ça me
paraît évident aujourd'hui de porter un
peu la voix des parents parce que c'est
une urgence très forte d'humaniser un
petit peu de secours de l'hôpital pour
leur dire ce qu'on risque aujourd'hui
c'est la vie de nos enfants et on doit
informer justement toute l'opinion
publique et leur dire que on attend des
réponses de la ministre agnès buzyn qui
doit rendre des comptes aux familles cet
hiver quelques lits ont été rouverts à
paris et l' agence régionale de santé a
mis en place une réunion de suivi
quotidienne avec l'ap-hp afin d'éviter
les transferts
une situation que dénonce gerald kerzec
médecin urgentiste réanimateurs les
responsables des fermetures de lits ce
sont justement les rs ces fameuses
agences régionales de santé et le
ministère de la santé
en sept ans il ya eu plus de 17000 lee
qui ont été fermés en france
à l'assistance publique-hôpitaux de
paris gare à paris il ya 900 lits qui
sont fermés en fait il ya deux raisons
il ya un les le manque de personnel et
on est un espèce de cercle vicieux pas
de personnel pas de lits mais
deuxièmement il ya une vraie volonté
technocratique administratifs
bureaucratiques donc de la rs des
agences régionales de santé de fermer
les livres
donc moi ça me fait doucement rigoler
comme mes collègues quand les rays dit
oui on va mettre en place un comité de
suivi etc
ce sont eux et responsable la fermeture
des lits alors que 1200 médecins ont
démissionné collectivement de leurs
fonctions administratives le 14 janvier
la ministre de la santé va t'elle un
corps d davantage de moyens à l'hôpital
public dont toutes les sutures craque